in 2003 speaking of the west coast apple
launched the world's most successful
digital download service the itunes
store we all know it and use it I'm sure
and now it's making a play into a field
that it has avoided for some reason for
years that's music streaming today the
company debuts Apple music offering
access to tens of millions of tracks for
a monthly fee Bloomberg pursuits Stephen
Pohl Viron joins us right now to talk
about what you've been testing haven't
you got a beta I got a little sneak peek
at WWDC the world wide developer
conference a few weeks ago but I haven't
actually been able to use it on my own
phone out of a kind of little test
environment and what do you normally use
so I'm normally a google play music
person but I at the start strange you
realize I mean very strange well
somebody that the bar everyone's like
wow really like the nerdy option but
it's you know that Spotify users oh and
you're Betamax like who uses that no I
know but i bet i delete it was the
better system you're too young to know
this but beta was the better system but
unlike title I think apple's gonna try
to use celebrity in a different way
they're gonna try to build some goodwill
with celebrity and they're gonna try to
bring some users over what does that
even mean really because a week another
thing is called celebrity no no no no no
see I got you so so title is the this
service with jay-z and deadmau5 right
right so yeah what title tried to do was
say this is a service for artists by
artists artists will get more money what
Apple's trying to say is yes we're gonna
pay artists more but this is also a
platform for artists to be creative you
can interact with artists they can have
this almost tumblr like platform to
share videos behind-the-scenes song
lyrics and things like that Apple wants
this to be a music magazine that's also
where you get your music from okay
that's what they want what do you think
it's gonna be a success I'm not sure
we'll find out at 11am eastern time this
morning the service goes up noon the
beats 1 radio station kicks off but it's
gonna take some time I mean I don't
think you can ever count Apple out
especially when this music service is
going to be the default music player on
exactly and that includes millions of
iphone that's the key right no matter
how many no matter how many Taylor Swift
sign up for title no matter how many
people use Spotify and I'm
most popular music streaming service I
know Stephanie uses it because of her I
even have it on my phone there's a
default to Apple even if it weren't
automatically on your phone because you
want to stay in the environment we echo
system is just so good that on many
levels unless this Apple venture is a
complete failure many people are simply
going to default to it right and when
you pull your new iPhone whether it's
the current iphone 6 or the next
generation out of the box there's going
to be a little icon that says music and
that's going to put you right into Apple
music so for people who don't want to
think a lot about it who haven't tried
510 services this is just going to be
music well and why bother if I can get
all of the songs that I want for a
similar price why would I bother using
another service right it's ten dollars
right because these services are now
saying they're offering different things
title for example is offering its users
invitations to exclusive events access
to certain artists so in this universe
where people don't want to pay for
products but they want to pay for
experiences it seems like that's what
these music services are leaning towards
spot if I didn't offer it and these new
guys it seems kind of that's their
calling card sure I think beats 1 radio
is Apple's kind of flagship product in
in this area so starting at noon today
Eastern Zane Lowe a famous DJ is kicking
off in Los Angeles the 24 hour radio
station so if you're an apple music
subscriber or even if you have an Apple
ID and don't pay for the service you can
access beats one and it's the same thing
for everybody across the world at the
same time and it's talk it's interviews
it's music it's behind the scenes looks
absolutely honest you're younger than
Matt and I did you know to Zane Lowe was
before he worked on this I did not know
who thing who is named Louis it's a
famous CJ he's a famous DJ used to be
with us can you be he was with BBC one
radio ah like a chris evans kind of
going kind of yeah except for we've
heard of chris evans my heart belongs
sure steven Pulver and thanks so much
for joining us associate editor at
bloomberg pursuits